les nouvelles technologies comme arme
diplomatique ce mardi matin des
centaines de millions d'indiens se sont
levés sans leurs applications mobiles
favorite
new delhi a en effet ordonné le blocage
de 59 application chinoise accusés
d'attenter à la sécurité nationale
compte tenu de la nature émergentes des
menaces le ministère des technologies de
l'information a décidé de bloquer 59
application car à la vue des
informations disponibles elles exercent
des activités préjudiciable à la
souveraineté et à l'intégrité de l'inde
à la défense de l'inde à la sécurité de
l'état et à l'ordre public
l'inde craint notamment pour la
confidentialité des données numériques
de ses administrés
mais plus qu'une menace pour sa sécurité
new delhi compte en réalité punir
symboliquement son voisin chinois
à l'origine de cette sentence un
accrochage militaire entre les deux
géants asiatiques il y a deux semaines
au nord-est du pays dans une région
frontalière contestée le face-à-face a
fait 20 morts côté indien
une première dans les relations
bilatérales depuis 45 ans une
escarmouche qui a profondément indignée
la population indienne et qui a poussé
le gouvernement nationaliste hindou a
répliqué et ce sont donc les
applications chinoises qui ont été
bannis du web indien dont la plateforme
de microblogging weibo certains services
de baidu le google chinois ou encore le
jeu clash of kings mais surtout la
célèbre et très populaire application
tik tok une plateforme de partage vidéo
qui compte plusieurs centaines de
millions d'utilisateurs dans le pays et
davantage encore à l'échelle mondiale
alors entre perte de leur réseau social
et sentiments patriotiques dans les rues
de new delhi les avis sont partagés
beaucoup de personnes pauvres ou
originaires de l'inde rurale qui n'ont
pas accès ou non pas la possibilité de
se faire un nom ont pu montrer au monde
leur talent sur tik tok
c'était une plateforme pour beaucoup
d'entre eux leur permettant de montrer
leurs talents et d'obtenir des
opportunités ce qui ne leur est pas
possible autrement
tik tok est une application qui aident à
montrer au monde leur talent
selon moi c'est une bonne idée
d'interdire les multiples applications
de chinoise en inde la sécurité serait
l'une des raisons pour laquelle ils ont
fait cela
à part cela une réponse économique là où
ça fait le plus mal devrait être là
parce que la chine agit comme une
hégémonie
vingt soldats sont morts donc les gens
ici sont en colère donc on veut
boycotter les applications chinoise
l'internet n'est d'ailleurs pas le seul
secteur à prendre part aux mauvaises
relations actuelles entre les deux
géants asiatiques
un groupe hôtelier de la capitale
indienne a annoncé que ces
établissements n'accueillerait plus de
clients chinois jusqu'à nouvel ordre
[Musique]